>> BYTTOW: My name is David Byttow and I'm
with my colleague Marcel Prasetya. And we're
going to be discussing how you can build smart
and scalable robots. We're going to be giving
some demonstrations of some robots today and
also cover some of the new things that are
going on and coming out. So with that, I just
want to jump over this switch or to a really
quick demo of a robot. I'm going to assume
most of you are familiar with robots but we're
just going to do that really quick. So I'm
going to search over the wave and I'm going
to add robot here, Davebot. So just like any
participant you go ahead and add a robot directly
to the wave and it immediately jumps in and
says, "Hello." Okay, so, hello. Talk to it;
it comes back and want to play game. This
is a robot I actually build to play games
with. If there's anyone who plays one game
right now, so, "Sure, why not?" So I immediately
jump in and put the chess gadget in. Now,
I just want to mention real quick that there's
no extra code here. This robot is actually
created to play chess after the chess gadget
is already created. This, in fact, was a gadget
that was created for players to play each
other. But, you know, robots have the same
rights as humans, so it works pretty well
if you code your robot to know what the state
of the board is. So I can come in and make
a couple moves, and just like any human player
the robot will start playing, so it jumps
in, make some move. I'll expect a couple more
of moves here. See, it's pretty responsive,
pretty quick. Of course, I know exactly what
it's doing, and of course, I fall for the
oldest trick on the book. So this is pretty
cool little chess robot. Again, I'd like--how
it's decoupled from the actual game, the robot,
so you can build multiple robots to use the
same chess gadget or whatever. So with that,
I'm going to switch back, oops, let's not
jump too far. Again, just like any slide,
where you have a wave. You could see the link
down here to ask questions and, you know,
we'll look at that towards the end when we
reach the end of talk and take questions and
answers. So, what I'm going to cover? What
are we going to cover, rather? First, I want
to give it a--just a quick overview of the
API. Again, this is kind of like, you know,
it's a two-in-one talk. So, I assume many
of you are familiar with the robot API and
have perhaps even used it. But I'm just going
to give a quick overview of what it is and
how it works from a high level architecture
standpoint. Then, we're going to cover what's
new in version two. In version two, we launched,
I guess, about a couple of months ago after
we received all the feedback and we kind of
rolled out a whole bunch of features all at
once, including active API and so on, so I'm
going to cover that. And then we're going
to do a deep dive. Marcel's going to come
up and talk about how you can build super
power robots. He's going to do that by going
over some of the features and best practices
of building robots, show us some code and
show a couple of cool little demos that kind
of open this up. And I should--I just want
also to point out that we're not just talking
about robots here because we're actually launching
data liberation, which means you can actually
access your waves and waves on behalf of other
users using OAuth and so on. And this opens
up a whole new category of applications built
on top of wave, you know, we could build stand
alone clients on any platform or whatever
you want to do and we'll kind of touch that
a little bit. And then we're going to go over
just a couple examples of robots that are
built today when just a little bit of disassembling
and say, "Well, what features do they use,
what makes them unique?" And finally I'm going
to talk about robot liberation which is something
that was announced yesterday during the keynote
by Larce and then a couple of other talks
and no longer do you have to run robots in
App Engine. And we think this is really cool
because you're not limited to Python or Java
anymore, and you can run on your own server
which is especially great for building your
own clients. So real quick wave in two minutes
or less; we're kind of all showing this on
different wave slides but this is the screenshot
of wave and, you know, our current tag line
is, well, "Get stuff done with groups of people".
Because we realized on the wave team that's
exactly what we do and various other teams
at Google as well, and it works very well
in that setting. And, of course, we have a
very simple sharing model, you know, you start
a wave, you add someone to that wave and now
they have access. You can, you know, jump
in and reply anywhere to the Wave. We have
the live concurrent editing which you're familiar
with and, of course, what this has built upon
is what we believe is actually really important
to the Wave ecosystem is the ability to add
custom extensions; in robots were just one
type of that extension. So that's all part
of the Wave client itself. So let's jump to
an overview. So what's robot? I mentioned
a robot has the same rights as a human. So
human can jump into a Wave start editing,
you know, replying anywhere, do whatever they
want, robots can do the same thing. It's very
important that we keep these two things in
locks up and keep them equal because, you
know, you want to be able to build robots
and it just as powerful as they're human counterparts.
And so, we do this using an HTTP based JSON
protocol to listen to the events and to respond
of operations. I'm going to discuss real quick
how that works and--so this is a quick screenshot
of, you know, human and robot. They all appear
on the participant panel the same and, in
fact, many times it's actually very difficult
to tell the difference between a human and
a robot, which I think is kind of a good thing.
So this is just a couple images here to give
a really, really high level overview of what
the protocol looks like. We have two things,
one we called active API and one we called
passive. Passive is what we originally launched
with. It was basically where you could say,
"Well, when I have this robot at appspot.com.
If someone adds that to a wave, whenever this
modifications is being done to that wave,
I want to know about it, so we send you a
JSON based request and then you can look at
that robot can rather and respond with operations
also with JSON based operation. So, it has
that kind of, you know, that loop, it was,
you know, don't' call us, we'll call you type
of model. With version two, we ruled out the
active API using OAuth encoded request so
that your robot can send operations directly
to our server without having to wait for any
kind of callback or anything like that and
that's great for Push, right. If you need
to push content to wave, let's say a Twitter
feed or whatever, you can just start waves
and start pushing content into them and adding
people and so on and so forth. And clients,
of course, would see that happen in real time
in there in the browser. So this is just a
real quick overview of the twp types of systems
we have. And as far as events go, so I mentioned
that you, you know, robot receives events
and then, you know, gives operations. So what
happens is when event happens on a Wave server,
we send you a JSON encoded message and it
has the contents of, well, what just happen
in that event, right. So before long here,
you know, Wave server receives an event like
someone edited something or whatever. We sent
that to one of our servers, we call the robot
proxy, and the server will take and concatenate
all the events that occur and look at the
robots through on those waves and put them
in a JSON based format that the robot requires
and send them out as HTTP request and wait
for a response and that response can include
operations. So this is sent via HTTP and this
is where the robot can actually process the
event and say, "Okay, well, someone added
this content and I need to look at it and
fix it up or whatever." And, in fact, that's
very much how our spell checker works Spelly
and Linky. You know, when you type a link
and wave, it looks like a link, so our robot
looks at and goes, "Yup, this is actually
a link," and trace a link out of it. So I
just wan to give a really quick look at what
this looks like. This is the wrong window.
So I'm going to switch over here and this
shows some JSON, very simple and I'm not going
to jump into it, but this is our protocol.
You can see we have, you know, the events
that occurred. For example, blips made an
event occurred. Someone submitted a blip.
Which way blip did this happen on, who edited
it, when did it happen, and what, you know,
what was part of that content. And this is
all the information you basically need in
order introspect and see--well, I care about
this or I don't care about that or whatever.
And then, of course, symmetrically there's
the operation side where once you receive
an event, you know, you look at it and go,
"Okay, that's great. I've seen this content.
So, now, I want to, you know, mess this up,
change this, annotate this content, add a
link, whatever, right, that all happens to
our operation protocol." So same thing, this
is all happens in a request. We actually send
this back via JSON RPC so you can batch them.
You say, "Well, here's a bunch of operation
I want you to play sequentially over the Wave
or over this content." Robot proxy then takes
it. This is our server. And looks at it, goes,
"Yup, this looks good, everything is great,"
and then applies them to the Wave server.
So just again let's take a quick look at what
that is. So this is some operation JSON, probably
maximizes more, but--so really all this is
a series of--it's an array of JSON RPCs saying,
"Look, I want to change a title. I want to
modify some content," whatever. So that's
great and that's the protocol, and we published
that so you can see. You go in kodakgoogle.com,
check it out. And it's very important that
we publish this because, as I've mentioned
before, we're opening this up beyond App Engine
to the point where, you know, you can build
client libraries to wrap that. And that's
what we did at first. We open source two libraries
Python and Java, of course, for App Engine
to handle that protocol for you. So you don't
have to deal with that. You could just focus
on modifying the model classes that we provided
wave, wavelet, blips and so on and just focus
on like modifying content and what the robot
actually does. And, of course, you know, what
about this other languages. Well, it's not
that we didn't like those other languages
or didn't want to support them. It's just
that, you know, we were limited by what App
Engine supported at the time. So I actually
think a Ruby client was actually created at
some point and I'm not sure how he did it,
but I think he might have done some kind of
proxying where, you know, you've receive an
event from those App Engine robot and proxy
it to his Ruby server and do something kind
of crazy. So, you don't do that anymore. In
just a really quick "Hello World", this is
in Python, it's one slide and the robots are
pretty dumb but, you know, it demonstrate
that we can have a very low little code. Actually,
you know, a robot participating in the conversation
and what this one does is, well, when it gets
added, it says, "Hey, you know, I'm here."
Makes itself known. And then when anyone ever
gets added to the waves, so if, you know,
you add the robot, then you add some friends
that robot will say hello to them, you know,
when they get at it into the wave, which isn't
really useful but still kind of interesting
in what three lines of code actually to do
that part. And--yup, so then, you know, we
have all these nice things, like, yeah, you
can do that that's kind of--it's like a toy
basically. So, we looked that and said, "What
do we need to do in order to make this really
interesting and really powerful?" So we came
up with the version two which has a few things.
It has more robust operations. These are operations
that will run both in the client and the server,
so you can say, "Look, find me this text,
find me some texts like searches for Google
and replace it with the link to, you know,
google.com." And so you would just send it
to the server and the server will run that
logic for you and it also run on your side
so that the content matches and we think this
is a much better way to, you know, to run
this kind of operations and rather than you
having to look at the indices and go in and
figure out what the annotation boundaries
should be and then send those off to the server.
And by that time, of course, because people
are typing in a Wave the content has already
changed and it doesn't mean anything and things
get all kind of crazy and out of control.
We don't want that. Next thing is bandwidth
control; because we were limited to App Engine
quota became very important. And, in fact,
there are a few robots that we launched and
they became and other people launched and
it became somewhat popular and all of a sudden
they stopped working. I said, "Well, why they
stopped working?" Because, of course, they
hit their quota, because they were seeing
so much traffic. And if someone--we have this,
you know, operation or we still do, we have
this event called document change. And document
change means, well, send me an event every
time any of the content changes. And you can
imagine, of course, if someone is in there
typing and editing blips, the robots are receiving
lots and lots of JSON, lots and lots of content
and then that will blow out your quota very
quickly. So what we did is we allowed to control
what you're interested in, so you can say,
"Well, I want to know when document changes,
but I only want to know if it contains, you
know, this regular expression or, you know,
whatever." Things like that, right, and that's
much more important because then the work
is done on the server as opposed to, you know,
us just sending you information and 99% of
the time doing well. This--I don't care about
this, just drop it on the floor. So, that's
very important as well. And then a couple
of the things, I'll just highlight real quick
are profile semantics. Now, you know, robots
can actually--well, they can also act on behalf
of the users but they can look like they're
from other users. So if you have a Twitter
stream coming in from a robot, you know, you
want to be able to actually say who is this
from, right, who is this post from. You show
their profile image, show their name and so
on. So, we allow you to do that with the system
we called proxy for which Marcel will cover
in. He has a pretty cool demonstration of
that in YouTube. And then finally, at Google,
we take data liberation very seriously. Meaning
that, well, any data you pt in to our services
you should be able to get out at any time
and take it to another service and with no
exception. Yup, we want you to be able to
input content into Wave whether it's through
the robot API or directly in Wave. And have
application developers write applications
that can pull your content, do something with
it, store it, whatever you need to do, you
know, to make it useful. So we did that to
allowing you to search cross waves and also
fetch wavelets. And so you can say, "Well,
I know I'm on this wave give me this content
and I wan to take it and store it and do something
with it later on or maybe push it back later."
So it's that whole two way transfer that we
have. And that's really, really important
to new applications that, you know, that we
think will be developed, you know, new clients
or Android applications or whatever, which
is very important. Yup, so with that, I'm
actually going to switch over to Marcel here
and he's going to go through a few of this
new feature and demonstrate them and give
a couple cool demos. So, Marcel.
>> PRASETYA: Thanks, David. Everyone my name
is Marcel Prasetya. I'm a software engineer
on the Google Wave team. Today, I'm going
to talk about some of the new features and
best practices on the Google Wave Robots API
version two that we launched a few months
ago. Some of the topics that I'm going to
cover are--first one is the new document modified
operation and then context and filtering and
then Proxy 4 and last one is the Active Robot
API. Now, without further ado let me just
jump in to the first one, the document modified
operation. So in the first version of our
API, in V1 most of our operations were index
and range base which result in a very error-prone,
fragile, and cumbersome API. So take for example,
if you want to replace all occurrences of
"foo" with "bar" in a blip, this is what the
code would look like in V1. So, first you
need to get the text view of the blip and
then you need to look over of all the occurrences
of "foo" in that text view and use that to
compute the range and then call the "textView.replace"
method in passing the range and also replacement
text. So we think that's just way too much
code for such a very simple operation. So
in the V2 API, we introduced this new operation
called document modify that allows you to
modify blip content without using index or
range as the reference. So in V2 replace "foo"
with "bar". The code will look like this,
"blip.allfoo.replacebar", so it's a lot simpler,
more readable and also more intuitive. Now,
let's take a look the components of this operation,
namely, the selectors and action. So I have
a simple code same as before "blip.allfoo.replacebar".
So the first part, "allfoo" is a selector.
So selector is something that restricts and
targets which part of the blip this operation
should be applied to. We support a few different
selectors. We have "all" and "first". And
should unique to apply operations using index
or range like in the V1 API, we also support
App in range selector. In second part, replace
bar is an action. So action is something that
dictates the server what needs to be done
on the regions that were match by the selectors.
We support insert, insert after, replace,
delete, and annotate. So I have a table up
here that show you the list of selectors and
actions that we currently support. Now, I'm
going to switch to my wave plan here and show
you a little demo of a wave robot that uses
this document modify operations to linkify
the word Google and YouTube. Okay, I have
my wave plan here. First of all, I'm going
to create a new wave with that robot in it.
I call my robot Wave Linky and I'm going to
type in something, "Hello, Google I/O. Have
you seen our video on YouTube?" And then hit
submit, so when I hit submit the Wave server
will broadcast an event, the blip submitted
event to the robot. So this Wave Linky robot
will receive that event including the blip
content and will search for all occurrences
of Google and linkify that, the same thing
with YouTube. As you can see now Google is
underlined, and if I click on this, I'll be
directed to google.com homepage, and the same
thing with YouTube. Okay, let me close that.
I'm going to switch back to my presentation.
So I'm going to show you the code to do that.
It's very simple. So it's just "blip.all["Google"].annotate("link/manual",
and then the google.com URL. So we use "all"
as the selector and "annotate" as the action.
And the same thing for YouTube, it's just
"blip.all["YouTube"].annotate("link/manual",
youtube.com". I'm going to show you a few
more sample codes here that uses document
modify operations. So the first one that have--next
to the Google example there is a gadget blocker
robot. So the code is "blip.all elementtypegadget.replaceblock".
So this code will look for all gadgets in
a blip and replace it with a text block. The
next example that I have here will look for
the first image in the blip and insert the
text TM. So the code is "blip.firstelementtypeimage.insertafterTM".
And the last example that I have--as I mentioned
before, we also support selectors that are
indexed and range-based, so I'm using range
here. The code is "blip.range6, 12delete".
So basically this will delete the blip content
from index 6 to 12. So that was document modify
operations. So, again, with this operation
you can do a lot of things, a lot of blip
content manipulation operations without worrying
too much about index or range competition.
So the next thing I'm going to talk about
is context and also filter. So in V2 API,
we give the robot more flexibility in controlling
how much data and how much events should be
broadcasted to the robot by specifying the
contexts and filters. So first one, context
specifies which blip should be included in
an event bundle if there is an event for that
robot. So you can specify Root, Parent, Self,
Siblings or Children as your context. Should
you need all the blips in that wave, you can
also specify all. The second one, filter.
So filter tells the server to only send an
event bundle to the robot if that event has
a property that matches the given regular
expression filter. So by specifying context
and filter properly, you could help to reduce
the bandwidth and CPU usage of your robot.
This is very true, especially if your robot
is listening to a very chatty event, for example,
the document change event, on a large wave.
And also, if you're using Google App Engine
as your hosting provider, App Engine has quotas.
So by specifying contexts and filters, you
can help to reduce your quota usage. Now I'm
going to show you a sample Java code on how
to specify contexts and filters. So I have
a simple event handler method here that handles
document change event. And the way you specify
contexts and filters are by setting them as
attributes of the capability annotation. So
I have @capabilitycontext=context.PARENT,
context.SELF and then filter is just the text
Google with double brackets. So what this
means is that the server will only broadcast
this document change event to this robot if
that even happens on a blip with the word
"Google" in it in double brackets. And also
when the server broadcasts this event to the
robot, it will include two blips in the event
bundle; namely, the blip where the event happens,
the SELF and also the PARENT blip of that
blip. So that's context and filter. Again,
with context and filter you could help to
reduce your bandwidth and CPU consumptions,
so you can be frugal with it. Next one I'm
going to talk about is the Proxying-for feature.
This is also a new feature in the V2 API.
So with this feature, a single robot can represent
many sub-participants in the format of robotid+proxyid@appspot.com.
So, in a way with Proxying-for, robot can
implement its own participant namespace. And
all events that are happening for the proxy
participants will be sent to that single robot,
so in this case it will be sent to this robotid.appspot.com,
and then that robot can process those event
bundles and then reply with operations on
behalf of those proxy participants. So robot
that acts as a gateway for an external service
provider, for example, like YouTube, Twitter
or Facebook could use the Proxying-for feature
to send operations kind of on behalf of that
service provider users. For example, like
A YouTube robot, youtube@appspot.com can send
replies and post comments back at the Wave
as if the comments were coming from a YouTube
user, like in this case user1, by sending
operations authored by youtube+user1@appspot.com.
Now I'm going to switch over to my Wave client
again. I'm going to show you a sample YouTube
robot that I had over the weekend. Let's see
if this work. So basically, this robot will
display the doctor Wave, Intro to Wave tutorial
video and also fetch the last three comments.
So first let me create a new wave with that
robot in it. It has a YouTube logo, so. All
right. So it displays the video in the ROOT
blip and then displays the last three comments.
Okay, so the last comment is from Road Biker,
"I like his lab coat." So I'm going to--now
I'm going to switch over to YouTube, just
reload this, just to make sure that the last
comment is indeed from Road Biker. Cocoballs,
click that. His name is Road. Okay. It says,
"I like his lab coat." Okay. All right. So
as you can see here, the comments were attributed
to the YouTube user. So like Sephora here,
Invictus1983 and Road Biker, they are not
Wave users; they are YouTube users. And if
you click on the participant profile on the
thumbnail here, you can disp--the profile
cart shows that this blip was actually created
by mprasetya-youtube, that is my robot ID,
plus Cocoballs, which is the YouTube user
ID, @appspot.com. So we use a YouTube user
ID as a proxy ID here. Also, you may wonder
how--like, "How does the client display this
custom profile information that's coming from
YouTube?" So when the server needs to render
a proxy participant, profile information,
it will actually talk to the robot. It will
make a profile request to the robot in passing
the proxy ID. The robot can take that proxy
ID, and in this case the YouTube robot will
use that to query the YouTube to give me a
profile information for Cocoballs. So then
YouTube will respond with the display name
here, Road Biker, and also the thumbnail URL
for this user. I'm going to switch back to
my presentation and show you the code to do
that. It's very simple. So first, the robot
will just fetch a comment from YouTube--it's
this line here--fetch a comment by from YouTube
and just passing the video ID. And I have
a separate method that makes the GData to
YouTube to fetch a comment. And then for each
comment, the robot extracts the user information
and use that to create a proxy version of
the wavelet by calling wavelet.proxy-for and
passing that YouTube user ID as the proxy
ID here. So once you have that proxy wavelet,
you can start making replies. So you can start
sending operations on behalf of that proxy
participant. So in this case, the robot calls
the reply method, "proxywave.reply" to post
the comment.
Okay. So that was Proxying-for. Again, with
proxying-for you can--if you built a gateway
robot that bridge Wave with an external service
provider, you can push contents into Wave
and properly attribute the contents--properly
attribute the blips with that service provider
user. So the next thing that I'm going to
talk about is the Active Robot API, which
was one of the topic classic features since
we launched the version one of our API. So
in VI, robot can only send operations in response
to events. So robots were passive. So it cannot
do anything useful until the server talks
to the robot or broadcast an event to the
robot. So then we decided in the V2 API, we
introduced this notion of the Active API,
where robot can send operations on demand
at any time to our server even outside the
event loop. So to accomplish this, we provide
an HTTP server that handles HTTP and HTTPS
request that robot can make the active calls
to this. Basically, the robot can just make
JSON RPC call to the server to send the active
call. So the call will be done over HTTPS,
so the data will be encrypted and also the
call will be signed and authenticated with
OAuth--with two-legged OAuth. So before you
can start using the Active API, you need to
register your robot to do this one-time registration
process to get your consumer Key and Secret.
Now I'm going to show you, again, with my
YouTube robot. So with the Active API, if
you have a gateway robot, for example like
this YouTube robot, you can make this robot
to push things or update Waves if there is
an event on the external service. So I'm going
to make this robot a little bit more interesting.
I'm going to introduce a cron job that will
periodically check YouTube and see if there
is any new comments on this Dr. Wave video.
And if there is one, it will post that new
comments back into wave.
Okay, so I'm going to switch over YouTube
and I'm going to post a new comment. I will
say, "I like his lab coat too," then hit post.
And I'm going to switch it over back to Wave
and if you're lucky, in a few seconds you
should see my new post. So, okay, there you
go. Hooray, it works. It didn't work this
morning. So basically this cron job will go
to YouTube using the YouTube Gdata API to
fetch for the last comment. And if there's
a new comment, it will make an active call
back into wave to post this new comment. So
I'm going to switch over to my presentation
and show you how to use Active API in your
code--robot code. So I have the robot--the
cron handler here. First thing that you need
to do is to establish your OAuth credential
by calling to set up OAuth method on the robot.
So call robot.setupoauth and pass in the consumer
Key and Secret. And then I'm going to create
a stop wavelet--so you can do this in two
ways. So you can create a stop wavelet by
calling robot.bindwavelet and then you can
apply operations to it or you can also fetch
the wavelet by calling robot.fetchwavelet.
I prefer to do the bind wavelet here because
it's faster and I don't need the actual Wave
content. And then I'm going to talk to YouTube
called this get comments method again to fetch
the new comments and use the technique that
we talked earlier in the Proxying-for slides
to post these new comments back to the Wave.
And then lastly, the most important bit in
the Active API is you need to actually submit
your pending operations by calling the submit
method. So you do robot.submit and you pass
in the wavelet in the URL, which is the URL
of the server that handles incoming active
call. So the URL here is HTTPS www.googleopensourceshell.googleuserscontent.com/apis/rpc.
So when you call submit several things will
happen. First, the client library will inspect
the operation queue of that wavelet and serialize
the pending operations into JSON. And then
once that's serialized it will prepare an
HTTP request. And they will sign that HTTP
request with OAuth using your consumer Key
and Secret and make an HTTPS call to the server.
So when the server receives this active call
request, first, it will validate the incoming
call to make sure that it hast he proper OAuth
signature just so that we can authenticate
like which robot is actually making this active
call. Once this succeeds validation, the server
will start applying the operation and you
can start seeing the updates in the Wave.
And then once the server is done processing
those operations, it will JSON RPC response
back to the robot. So then you can inspect
if there is any error or if there is any other
message in the response. Okay. So one other
thing that I would like to mention here--so
someone just replied. Is it one of you guys?
So as you probably noticed before, like I
didn't do anything in this Wave. I did not
type anything, I did not add a participant,
I did not submit a blip. I didn't do anything.
So it was purely the robot that's making active
callback into the Wave server. So again, that's
Active API. So with that, you can start pumping
operations day-in and day-out to our Wave
server. All right, so now we've talked about
some of the best practices and the new features
in the V2 API, I would like hand the floor
back to David to do some deep dive on some
sample robot. David?
>> BYTTOW: Yeah. Is my mic on? No. Sound?
Yes? Okay, good. Perfect. Right. So I want
to stop there real quick and just give a couple
of opinions. So Marcel, you know, covered
about, you know, how to push data into Wave.
But really recently, we actually--and this
is a leading edge, I guess--opened up the
ability for you to push content to Wave on
behalf of other users using what we call or
what OAuth calls three-legged OAuth. This
is--I know I said a number of things are important,
but to me especially very, very important
and going to be very, very interesting, right?
Because, you know, love it or hate it, you
don't need to go to our client anymore. We
can actually build applications, allow you
to use Wave as a platform, right--remember
this product platform and protocol--it's a
platform for your data, right? And you get
all the concurrency, you get all the active
push, you get all the, you know, everything
that Wave is known for but without having
to actually go to the client. And so, you
know, in the next couple of weeks we're going
to be rolling out more documentation and more
examples of this, you know, with an Android
application sample with, I guess we can call
it maybe a Wave light-type implementation
of a client. And, you know, I'm really, really
interested to see what the developers could
do with that to kind of, again, circumvent
the clients and push and extract content directly
out of the platform that we've built. So I
just wanted to stop and mention that. And
now I'm going to jump over to just a few examples
of robots using some of the things that Marcel
pointed out. Well, one is Monty. And this
is actually a robot that I built, I guess,
last year. And I just want to show it really
quick because it does--it's fairly interesting
to kind of see how Wave can be used as almost
like an IDE or an interactive IDE. So what
Monty does is it's a Python interpreter or
a Python-based robot that evaluates Python
code that you put into Wave and then it outputs
the result directly. So, you know, you can
communicate or you can--we have a tag line--you
can collaborate on the code directly and have
the robot run it. And the features that are
used are wavelet self added and then blip
submit it; very simple, nothing complex going
on. So let's just jump over to demo real quick.
I'm going to attempt to write some code directly
in Wave here. So I add Monty and it says,
"You have to input the program" and so I'm
going to input, say, a Fibonacci program--by
the way, there's a bug in this code and if
you can point it out after this is over, perhaps
at the mic, we'll send you a T-shirt. So let's
do this. Right. Okay. So now, I should just
be able to--we have this little wave.setresults--results.
So this should give me the output of Fibonacci
of 10. All right, so 89, which I do know is
the output of 10. And of course you can come
in and change or add other people to do it
and, you know, do whatever you need to do
to your program. You can modify it live. I
don't know, I guess that's probably right.
So yeah, so of course you can come in and
also let's say you have an error in your program,
Monty will tell you that, "Well here's the
error." So it's, you know, again, this is
actually a robot that was written in very
few lines of code. I can hop over that, show
you--this is the entire program written in
Wave actually. So there's just some code that--this
is all of the Python's specific code that
will actually run the program for you. And
then down below is the Wave code that says
well when a blip submitted comes in. If this
is the root blip, that's good. I'm going to
process it. Otherwise, just jump out, execute
the program, and then take the content and
output it to the first blip and just feed
the result directly through. Very simple but
yet very powerful and again as I was saying,
you know, this doesn't have to be done in
the client, all right? And with this, and
with the OAuth-enabled system, you can actually
build an IDE that pushes content into Wave.
Allows people to collaborate on it and get
results back and still use robots, and all
of that sort of thing so, It'll be interesting.
Mr-Ray. Mr-Ray is actually one of my favorite
robots because it kind of goes into the direction
that I'm talking about with alternative clients.
So what Mr-Ray does, it's actually very clever
and very well architected. It allows non-Wave
users to actually participate in conversations
when they're not on Wave, Yeah? So how do
you do that? Well, you don't--you make it
so that they don't have to go into Wave to
actually participate this is actually really
clever. And this is probably the reason why
it won first place in the --Mashable put on
an API contest and Mr-Ray, I think, took that
pretty quickly. So some of the features, it
uses our Proxy-For, which Marcel demonstrated.
Because if someone's going to be--if you're
going to be pushing content to wave, you need
to know who is this, right? If there's some
other joschmo@gmail.com, it needs to, you
know, reply--you're communicating with them
and they reply to the Wave. Well, you need
to know that, that's where it's coming from
and not actually the robot itself. And I'll
show you what I mean by that. And also I want
to say that it also uses the gadget for control
flow, right? That's a typical pattern that
people use. The robot inserts the gadget.
It's kind of like a Control Panel fuse. Again,
it's very clever. So I'm not going to show
the whole thing. I'm just going to jump over
to some examples that I have. So I have a
Mr-Ray wave, right, where I actually have
Mr-Ray on the Wave and I've added myself,
my personal Gmail, and myself, my other self
to the Wave. And you can see here there's
this control panel where I've added myself.
And this is a simple conversation. Now these
avatars could be changed but, right now, it's
using a, you know, just a little simple and
denoting that's coming from Mr-Ray. But this
is actually from, you know, crazy waver which
is the Gmail account of this wave account.
And so there's a conversation going on here.
So if I switch back and I say, "Hey," now
what that other user has is a client to actually
go and see that content and reply to it. So
if I jump back to my links, this is what they're
presented with when you add them to this wave
with Mr-Ray, not the redirect notice. They're
presented with an actual, yes. So, this is
kind of a like, you know, it's a view of the
Wave. It's--it got some buttons for reply.
It's simple but it's--it works, all right?
And even more so now, you don't need to do
these with robots anymore, you can actually
do it with having the user log in to this
and authenticate with us, come back, and now
they're authenticated to our wave client.
You can push content directly in on their
behalf. You don't have to do any kind of proxy
for anything like that. They're an actual
user at that point. So, you know, you of course,
you can reply, you know. And same story, it'll
push the content back and I come back into
Wave, and of course, it's there, yep. So,
again it's--it is an alternative client, right?
And it's very neat, very clever. And then
just one more robot I want to show before
we jump into the robot liberation is Ferry.
Now this--I wanted to show this because, you
now, one of the themes of I/O is enterprise
development. And aside from, you know, nice
little toys and robots and such, it's very
important that you'd be able to get your content
into other services, right, like Google Docs
for example. And Ferry does just that. It
exports waves into Google Docs and allows
you to take it and save it there and modify
it and collaborate that way and then push
content back into wave. So I'm just going
to demonstrate that very quickly. It uses
OAuth, by the way, for access. So when you're
in Wave, you can grant access to Google Docs
or grant access to the robot on your behalf
for Google Docs. I set it right the first
time. So let's jump over here and look at
a wave. So, it's very simple to use. You install
Ferry through the extension gallery and it
shows up on the Tool bar when you're in edit
mode. So I started this document. I can actually
probably just through it real quick and give
you a quick demonstration, so again, sample
document, pretty boring. Let's pretend this
is a really long document that I've--we've
been working on collaborating on and so on.
"I can't type, when I'm on that school." So
on the Tool bar, you'll see that there's this
is icon which is available. So you click that
icon, Ferry jumps on the Wave and goes, "Okay
I want to access this." Here's again, another
gadget used for controlling what's happening
rather than, you know, having to parse text
and so on. It works very, very well. So, yep,
I'm just going to say, "Go," "Great," click
here to grant access. It does a little OAuth
dance. Yep, grant access. Of course, once
you're authenticated, you should remain authenticated
at that point. I think I clicked it. Anyway,
I'm going to jump over here and, okay so this
says it will sink automatically. It's a little
bit slow. Yep, an error occurred, perfect.
So--but luckily I did creates a document before
I ran through this, just before the demonstration
or just before the session. And I do have
a document which is very similar. Which is,
again, this is a sample document. You can
look at this in Docs, and it's a nice way.
And now this is was just a start. Yeah, there's
actually a talk later on today which describes
getting content in and out of Wave. It's the
media APIs and it's more than just documents.
It's also images and attachments and so on.
But you can see that the robot API is the
least powerful now for it allow you--allowing
you to do this sort of thing, you know, today.
So, that was a few robots. Robot Liberation,
now this actually was something we've been
talking about. You know, we realized over
the last year, we've given a number of talks
and it always said, "Well, today robots run
an App Engine. But tomorrow, that, you know,
we promise we'll open it up." And you know,
for one reason another, we're working on,
you know, with our limited resources, working
on some, a lot of the other features that
Marcel demonstrated. So a few weeks ago, we
said, "Well, why haven't we done this yet?"
There's not really a great reason. And it's
a really big bang feature, right? So we did
it. And it works today. We're going to be
rolling out some more documents over the week
to make it easier in a few updates. It's not
as seamless as I'd like it today admittedly,
but it will be very soon. But it does work.
So I just mentioned all that. I'm not going
to go over how it works completely. And it's
not that important. And there's a flow where
essentially you, you know, same old story
where you have your URL that you want your
robot to live on or rather you want events
to be sent to that URL, yeah. And then, well,
you have to say prove ownership of that domain
or that URL. So what we do is we have a form
where we'll say, "Look, this is what I want
my robot ID to be," which would be something
like, you know, "waverobot@googlewaverobots.com",
which by the way means we're moving away from
appspot.com and onto our own domain. And this
is my URL. We got a prove ownership. So we
give you a token that you have to serve up
and then you come back, click verify. We make
sure you put that token on that URL, rate,
and we issue you your ID, we issue you your
consumer keen secret, and off you go. And
you can add that robot. So there was a Go
talk earlier today. And, you know, "Go" is
an interesting language to me. I don't really
know it. but I want to learn it. But there
was a developer who really likes wave and
his on the Go team. So when he found out that
we were opening up robots like this literally
two weeks ago, he built a client library.
And he's still working on. It'll be open source
very soon. And I said, "Well, that's great.
That's awesome. Let's demo that." So that's
what we're going to do real quick. Just, you
know, it's a very simple--simple robot. Before
I actually show the demo, I just want to highlight
the code for a Go robot. It looks very similar
to Python. It's very easy to use. If you're
familiar with Python, you'd be familiar with
how to use the Go language. And all this does
is a simple hello world. The robot demo I'm
going to show is actually a little bit more
sophisticated. So let's do that. So I'm going
to jump over here, actually to my Sandbox.
Again, I should--I forgot to mention that
our Robot Liberation is only available on
Sandbox today, very soon. It'll be available
on the--on our public instance. And I promise
it won't take as long as it took for us to
get off of that [INDISTINCT], it will actually
be very soon. So, jump over here. And you'll
see that I can add GoBot. Actually before
I do that, I'm going to submit this blip.
Oops. I'm here at GoBot. So, GoBot is actually
at googlewaverobots.com. And I can show you
that it's actually not an App Engine. Okay,
he says, "Hi." If I click his profile, you
can see that his website--actually, that doesn't
prove it. But I assure you that this is not
running on App Engine. This is running on
his VPS. And, you know, we're just--you know,
we're just sending request directly to that.
So if I come over here, I'd say, "Hi." Go
is a new programming language. Go, and then
of course you can reply. And it's very quick.
You notice that things are much snappier these
days, which is great. And it can embed, you
know--embeds a video about Go and so on. So,
you know, very basic but he know, he built
this in literally a week. And we're excited
to see, you know, various other languages
being used and it's great because, you know,
with App Engine, App Engine is stateless,
right? So anything that comes in, you get
a request. You send a response back. If you
want to store any kind of state, you have
to store it in datastore. It's a little bit
tricky. But when you're running on your own
server, you can have locally cached states
and so on and so forth, so that's great. And
then, you know, there's a number of other
languages and things could be ported to. I
don't--I just came up with the list. I had
another one in mind but I never typed it.
That's the empty bullet point. So hopefully
we'll, you know, see some of these very soon,
using our protocol. Everything I mentioned
today, and Marcel mentioned, is available
in example, except for the little anecdotal
stories, at code.google.com/api/wave. Like
I said, we're going to be diligently updating
the documentations or the documentation. And
you know, with how to liberate your robots
and the OAuth stuff which is going to be pretty
interesting. So, we look forward to that.
And yep, so that pretty much concludes our
talk. I just want to thank you for coming
and listening to this. We're going to check
out the Wave, see if there's any questions.
Otherwise, please you know, feel free to ask
a question on the mic. Again if you saw a
bug on the Fibonacci program, feel free to
mention that too and we'll send you a T-shirt.
So, yep, so that's it. Thank you. Hi there.
Oh, we got--okay, so yes, sir.
>> Robot liberation is very exiting, I was
wondering if you have a fine grain timescale
as to when we can expect that documentation.
>> BYTTOW: Yep, so I think the documentation
is available now, as far the flow goes. So--in
fact, I ran to the registration just before
this session, it's all good. The only thing
that's changing is just a few updates to make
it a little bit easier to do, right, because
right now, you register your ID. If it's a
taken ID, it's not clear immediately. But
bear with us there and we'll be fixing it
up.
>> Super, thank you.
>> BYTTOW: Yep.
>> Hi. I may have just missed the slide. But
in your Cron handler method that was getting
called periodically, how do you actually route
a URL to that method?
>> PRASETYA: Oh, so--so for my example robot
I just use App Engine Cron or App Engine Task
Queue, you can do that.
>> Okay. And you can like directly assign
your method to an action that occur periodically?
>> PRASETYA: So, yeah--so, the way App Engine
Cron and the Task Queue work is just basically
a servlet that App Engine system will call
in a period of time. So, it's--so that you
can just put that method inside a servlet.
And inside the get handler, you can just call
that method.
>> Okay. And okay, that will [INDISTINCT]
the API for that. And the Fibonacci sequence
I believe is incorrect for an argument of
zero.
>> BYTTOW: Zero and one.
>> Yes.
>> PRASETYA: Yep.
>> BYTTOW: Yes, that's right. Good job. Oh,
let me jump over to the Wave, because--let's
see if there was anything real quick. If anyone
else has any question, feel free to jump on.
Is this half of the thing? No.
>> PRASETYA: Oh, like, no light wave, yeah.
>> BYTTOW: [INDISTINCT]
>> PRASETYA: No, this one here.
>> BYTTOW: Sure. We're just going to check
real quick I think one of the questions someone
asked was, when can Skype be used as a bot?
You know, I don't think we're going to be
supporting in for like that any time soon.
But we have talked about either, you know,
voice integration or whatever in Wave in general.
But as far as the Skype bot goes, you know,
I mean I guess it could technically feasibly
be built but, you know, I don't know if anyone's
working on that. I know there are voice chat
applications that are in Wave today, though.
Our wave now trashed. So it seems like--just
real quick--yeah, I guess one question I wanted
to jump up is what's the best way to have
a robot interact with participants on a wave
replying using a gadget or so on. I just want
to say it's up to you. You saw that, you know,
you can use gadgets to control the flow. I
think that's one great way of doing things,
so.
>> PRASETYA: Yes. That's it.
>> BYTTOW: Anyway guys.I'm sorry, yes sir.
>> Is there an example, you may have or you
may have seen whether it's like an [INDISTINCT]
type robot that can interact in--I'm interested
in like making a little customer service type
application where somebody could visit website,
they could view that page, and they could
sort interact in like a sort of human fashion
and then be handed off to a real human if
the robot can't handle the situation.
>> BYTTOW: Totally, so...
>> PRASETYA: Yes.
>> BYTTOW: We've always wanted to make our
robots more conversational in that way, right?
To seem like you're actually communicating
with something. You know, a lot of--the call
services do that. You can ask questions like,
"Nope. Okay, no. Let's fall back to a real
human." I think that's true and also you can
actually build web applications that, you
know, that's on your website where you're--you
can, you know, be getting content back and
forth from Wave, alright, and actually have
people maybe go into wave, you know, if you
have someone working on, you know, someone
working at some company or something that
gets these waves that get questions feed it,
fed into them, And they can reply and then
of course those replies will be pushed back
out to your robot or to your service to kind
of close that loop, right? So you can use
it for that kind of communication loop and--either
way, it could be a robot or human participant.
I don't know if that answers your question
directly but you know we can talk a little
bit more about that.
>> PRASETYA: Yeah, so basically inside your
robot event handler, you can just do whatever
you want, including like making, you know,
HTTP call to somewhere or sending emails or
basically, yeah, just integrating that to
into your service.
>> BYTTOW: Yes, but what you're saying is
something that you've always thought, would
be a great use in this case.
>> PRASETYA: Yes.
>> BYTTOW: Nope. All right, well again, thanks
guys. Yes sir, sorry.
>> Just a...
>> BYTTOW: Really bad at looking [INDISTINCT].
>> Just a quick question, is there any plan
for wizards for making robots in the Eclipse
plug in?
>> BYTTOW: Yes, there's--if I understand your
question correctly, there is a robot, so like
a tutorial, like a helper for building robots
you mean?
>> I'm sorry could you--can you repeat.
>> BYTTOW: You said, you--like a wizard or
helper for building robots?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> BYTTOW: Yep, there's robot-robot.
>> PRASETYA: Yes, so robot-robot is a robot
IDE inside wave. So but I think your question
was about if there--if we have any Eclipse
plug in for robots API or not? Right?
>> Yeah.
>> PRASETYA: So we currently don't have that.
But that's something--really something that
we should keep in mind. I think--typically,
when I develop a new robot, I install the
App Engine plug in for Eclipse and that's
very convenient for me. And I think we should
definitely look into that too.
>> Yeah, that's what I use too. I was thinking
of graphical wizards that would ask questions
to the user, to the coder then--and then generate
a skeleton of robots.
>> BYTTOW: We actually had an intern on the
team build a kind of a meta robot that adds
a gadget. And you can actually construct logic
through a flowchart-like system.
>> Yeah.
>> BYTTOW: And we haven't released that yet.
We've just kind of kept it internally so far.
But it's great for building tutorial robots,
so. Tutorial being like Wave tutorial or whatever.
So you would say like, you know, do this and
branch on this when the user like presses
enter or replies and it kind of just, you
can build a simple conversational robot graphically,
so.
>> Very nice.
>> BYTTOW: Yep.
>> Is it possible to see a screen capture
of it?
>> BYTTOW: Not yet, but I'm--now that, you
know, that there's interest, I know we've
been planning to either push it out. We want
to push out some example at least very soon.
So we'll probably publish the code and do
that because it's really...
>> Thank you.
>> BYTTOW: Sure. All right, thanks guys.
>> PRASETYA: Thanks guys for coming.